well if you listen to the delusional
liberal media it's apparently Joe
Biden's best week ever Politico
declaring the president is back in the
game the same week the U.S entered a
recession they said quote somehow Some
Way Joe Biden is back in the game after
enduring a brutal year dominated by
economic angst legislative setbacks and
stinking approval ratings the president
is suddenly on the verge of a turnaround
that the White House believes could
Salvage his summer and alter the
trajectory of his presidency liberal van
Jones also thinks things are turning
around for Biden but it comes with a
major caveat if you just erase the past
six months of nutty stuff it looks like
you've got a president to get an
infrastructure Bill done get covered
stuff done uh get something done for the
American people on climate get something
done on chips that's a successful
presidency you just you know had the
past six months of nonsense it takes
away from so digging it seems like Ron
clane's been talking to Politico about
his outlook for President Biden yeah
it's
the what is Van Jones talking about so
all of the spending is what brought on
this skyrocketing raging inflation the
spending out of the White House and then
the j-pal central bank that was just
again sopping up all the spending and
juicing the economy so they want more of
it clearly you have a Federal Reserve
that's trying to fight this inflation
but at the same time just in the last
week the chips Bill and then this
Schumer Mansion enrichment green
monstrosity combine those that's more
than 700 billion dollars in additional
spending additional stimulus so you're
feeding the Beast of inflation you're
not helping the FED fight it also the
extending the student well the
moratorium on student loan payments
again inflationary handout to wealthy
doctors and lawyers the more the that
the bite Administration keeps spending
and feeding inflation the harder it is
for the central bank j-pal and the FED
to fight it and the higher rates go
you're looking at a like a leveraged
economy entering Armageddon where you
have a collapse in housing you have a
collapse in all assets you have a
recession that doesn't run two quarters
but that runs literally years instead of
a recession you know inflation recession
I call it the never-ending circle of
succitude I'm So tireless the White
House keeps saying we're now in a
transition to stable growth now that the
economy is Contracting which is negative
growth that's not growth hashtag said no
one uh I feel like the new speechwriter
obviously worked for the Detroit Lions
ticket sales department like you know
we're just going to put years of never
even coming close to the playoffs it's
all good now you know sorry dear I had
an affair for the last six months but
the rest of our marriage has been
wonderful like this is this is the
problem van literally and I love I think
van is has a great voice and I have a
lot of respect for him but literally I
think it was three weeks ago he was
talking about how the president had
failed black voters and he had failed
the Democratic Party by not falling
through anything what has happened since
then like this is the messaging it's
start telling the truth because if this
Administration
I can take bad news America can take bad
news be honest with us quit changing
words quit saying things quit painting
pictures that aren't there listen we're
in a recession and we're going to get
out of it and here's how you're going to
feel this pinch this is going to happen
and we're fighting to do this Americans
will listen to that whether you voted
for him or not you can you can accept
that okay but when you treat us like we
don't understand and you change words
and you have he comes on there like that
going well if you just take out the last
six months you don't you're the
president United States you don't get to
do that it is the worst job in the world
but the only people they're talking
about plus is CNN the only people
they're talking to is themselves
Americans are not listening to that and
you will see that in November so Harold
despite Joe Biden being the least
popular president since World War II
I'll give him the win on the chips bill
yeah he did it the Senate's you know
looking like it's leading Democrat in
Nevada and in Georgia not good for
Republicans but that doesn't mean that
there's a comeback here when it comes to
President Biden himself so I I don't
look I didn't mean to be flipping he's
certainly I like to call balls and
strike his numbers are in the 30s
they're bad
however it's one election at a time in
the country and generally a first term
president is is judged heavily by how
his party does or one day we'll see her
in the first in the first two years now
in a generic polling amazingly to many
and perhaps surprisingly to some
including myself Democrats are ahead by
two to three points within the margin of
error based on what voters want in terms
of a a party person uh that party in in
office two in Georgia in Pennsylvania in
Ohio
um in in Wisconsin Democrats are running
ahead in the Senate races now if
Democrats hold the Senate if not at a
seat or two or maybe more if they don't
lose the house even if Joe Biden's in
the 30s The Narrative automatically
changes we all know politics and have
been in and around it whomever we want
to blame we can blame but voters own
elections now the narratives change for
him the chips Bill the infrastructure
bill you can see how you could write a
speech around this Iris and say hey we
did some things uh the country we took
us a while to get here but we found a
way on guns we got a deal there I got a
deal on chips I got a deal on
infrastructure we're working on covet
that still may not be enough for him but
remember the presidency is not one year
it's not one and a half or two years
it's a four-year deal and if he if
Democrats hold in the midterms
um you got to think it votes well for
for Biden two years later oh Joey Joey
also though the people running for
office as Democrats are running far away
from Joe Biden he's not on the campaign
trail with these people they don't want
him to show up also the media's defense
of the White House language changing the
definition of things like recession
they're relying on that a lot in terms
of the narrative here now politics might
be the one sport you can't score on
defense and if you're going out and
explaining why recession recession isn't
recession you're probably not scoring
points you're probably not doing well
I'll also say if you want to invoke
something like Georgia's Senate race to
show how well the president's doing
you're carrying a lot of water no
because it's only saying the politics
the president is only the leader of the
democratic party it seems when it's
convenient for him to be the leader of
Democrat Party he gets to win on chips
but he doesn't carry the baggage of some
of the things uh that fail like his
agenda that failed in Congress I think
the Senate has a lot to do with this to
make up of the Senate I think that Mitch
McConnell got his butt handed to him
this week through uh through either bad
tactics or not having his eye on the
ball I guess Republicans can always say
thank God we got three Supreme Court
justices in because the Senate would
pass almost two trillion dollars in
spending but they won't do the pact act
this week because they want to be
fiscally responsible so and I know there
are things with that but my point is
Optics regular Americans don't
understand every little Nuance when it
comes to how bills are passed understand
enriching the rich which that
semiconductor Bill did that is a
lucrative high margin business that's
loaded that needed no money and 17
Senators 15 of which aren't up for
re-election signed on to it so far
Republicans have joined Democrats on 1.3
trillion dollars in spending this
Congress they could have run on
inflation the baby formula shortage gas
prices and they gave it away and now
they're they're rudderless these
Republicans uh well the Chip's bill was
actually introduced in a way by the
former Administration by Secretary of
Pompeo because it was a national
security it was introduced
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else